we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
it uh gives me no pleasure to bring this
to you today
it's a milestone that we've been warning
about
for months at this point and it's a
horrible milestone
as coronavirus cases and subsequently
deaths have climbed
we hit 2 000 deaths per day again and we
went past it
i've been saying that by the end of this
month we will likely be seeing
a 9 11's day worth of deaths
every single day from coronavirus and we
are essentially there
yesterday was the worst single death day
since the start of the pandemic 2833
people died in one day
depending on how you measure the day the
exact 24 hours
johns hopkins actually has a higher
number above 3 000 but this is
roughly essentially the number of people
killed on 911
directly by the events now the number
it's 29.77 i believe is the official
number of 9 11 deaths
on 9 11. now this doesn't include people
that died in the days after
due to uh stress-induced heart attacks
and
and first responders who later developed
illness because of their presence at
ground zero
so the number is really quite a bit
higher but on the day of 9 11 at the
sites of the disaster
it's considered to be just under 3 000
and that's where we are we are likely
to significantly exceed this daily death
number
for much of the remaining month and half
the country
is barely willing to alter their lives
in any way
as a result and 9 11 is an interesting
event to think about because think back
to 911 we as a result of one day of 3000
people
tragically dying completely reformed
airport security and created
a massive i mean gargantuan
infrastructure
through which we now all go when we fly
tsa was created the patriot act was
passed
justifying invasions of privacy on the
basis of keeping us safe
we attacked a country and got involved
in a multi-decade military engagement
the wrong country by the way
uh we i believe also created the
department of homeland
security maybe another agency all
because of 911 and now we have a 9 11
every day at this point 300 000
approaching 300
000 dead nationally from the entire
pandemic
and nearly half the country doesn't want
to do
anything about this 9 11's worth of
deaths
every single day now as a reminder
uh coveted deaths lag cases at this
point it's by about a month
we are now at about 100 000 people
hospitalized nationally with the virus
that's a record
which means that the next month is going
to be
absolutely insane and as you can see
when you look at a chart of cases
of those hospitalized and deaths you see
hospitalizations are approaching nearly
double the record we had we had about 60
000 hospitalizations during the first
spike in april
we had about 60 000 hospitalized in the
second spike in july
we are now at about 100 thousand
hospitalized and continuing to climb
notice how deaths track hospitalizations
in the second spike deaths didn't climb
as much
and that's because hospitals had more
capacity we are now starting to see
hospitals fill up again and it all bodes
really really poorly now we're expecting
vaccine approval
for one vaccine next week another
vaccine shortly thereafter
it will take months to roll that out the
numbers we might see
in the rest of december into january
into february even into march
depending on how quickly these vaccines
are deployed these are going to be
completely nightmarish numbers we're
almost living in two realities
sadly you look at what public health
experts say and we have a dire
disastrous situation
you look at the instagram and facebook
pages of nearly half the country
people behaving like nothing is going on
it is truly
nuts and the next month is next month is
going to be
terrible uh you really have to see this
we heard from the president yesterday
donald trump published a completely
deranged
and bizarre 46 minute video
to facebook after another week went by
without seeing him except on the golf
course continuing to promote laughable
and
even conflicting conspiracy theories
about the election
this was promoted as being maybe the
most
important speech ever from the president
and they were merely the rantings of a
madman who cannot accept that
he simply lost an election so i want to
go because we have so much to talk about
today
i want to go right into one of the most
cartoonish moments of this
speech which is trump holding up of this
blown-up
chart of the vote count in wisconsin
where as predicted early voting was more
leaning trump because of in person i'm
sorry early is a confusing term
in-person voting led to early numbers
that looked better for trump
and then as the mail-in ballots were
counted as expected it shifted more in
the direction of joe biden so
trump now going back a month trump still
thinks he has something here
to the vote count sequelae in wisconsin
listen to this that
wisconsin we're leading by
a lot and then
at 3 42 in the morning
there was this it was a massive dump
of votes mostly biden
almost all biden and to this day
everyone's trying to figure out where
did it come from
but i went from leading by a lot
to losing by a little
and that's right here that's at 3 42 in
the morning that's wisconsin
a terrible thing there is just so much
here that is wrong
much of it i'm sure you can tell right
away one of the things that is happening
frequently is they keep talking about
the times of day when votes were counted
as part of the suspicion
uh this happened at 3 42 in the morning
well it's election night and they're
counting ballots now what you have to
understand this is one of those
indefeasible talking points
in other states when they stopped
counting
that was also suspicious so really
understand the absurdity here in some
states they have rules like pennsylvania
was one such state
where they stopped counting for the
night on election night at some point it
might have been 10 or 11 pm eastern
in pennsylvania and you had people
saying that's suspicious
dave rubin's saying what they needed
naps or something
really weird that all of a sudden they
just stopped counting for the night
that was suspicious here in wisconsin
it's suspicious that
they were still counting at 3 42 in the
morning it's an
indefeasible argument you can't overturn
the argument you can't combat the
argument
because both sides are evidence of the
same conspiracy
stopping the count is strange
counting at 3am also strange trump then
continues and says the election was
rigged and everybody knows it
this election was rigged everybody knows
it
i don't mind if i lose an election but i
want to lose an election fair
and square what i don't want to do is
have it stolen from the american people
that's what we're fighting for and we
have no choice to be
doing that we already have the proof we
already have the evidence
and it's very clear many people in the
media
and even judges so far have refused to
accept it now this is really orwellian
double speak where everything is
backwards everything is the opposite
trump says the judges and the media
won't accept it
judges looked at the so-called evidence
and determined it was without merit so
they threw out cases
the media did accept that joe biden
won so it's a completely backwards
alternate reality
let's look at a little bit more they
know it's true they know it's there
they know who won the election but they
refuse to say
you're right our country needs somebody
to say you're right
so once again this is this is projection
trump knows
it's true that joe biden won and it's
childish
to keep pretending otherwise we'll
continue
ultimately i am prepared to accept any
accurate election result
and i hope that joe biden is as well
this is part of the continued play to
make it
seem as though there is a doubt about
the result
joe biden and the media and most of the
american people
have accepted the real results and
it's trump and his followers that
haven't accepted the results it's
it's all just backwards and then again
trump brings up this idea of proof
but we already have the proof we already
have
tens of thousands of ballots more than
we need
to overturn all of these states that
we're talking about
this is an election for the highest
office
in the greatest country in the history
of the world
every reasonable american should be able
to agree
based on what we have already documented
that we need
a systematic analysis of the mail-in
ballots to review
the envelopes now this is sort of a gish
gallup
we have tens of thousands of examples
from all over the country
that's not how we do it we look at one
by one
judges in various states look at
examples
from those states and they look at the
examples and make a determination about
their merits and in
each individual instance there was no
merit
this is a common debating technique and
trump is doing gish galit by ballot
for lack of a better term saying we have
tens of thousands of examples in all
these different states that's not how we
analyze it we look at these individually
and individually they have been found to
be without merit just a little more
video here
this is the absolute minimum we should
expect
this is not just about my campaign
although it has a lot to do with who's
going to be your next president
this is about restoring faith and
confidence
in american elections the party that has
been trying to suppress the vote for a
decade
now says we need to restore confidence
donald trump's attorney general william
barr one of the most biased partisan
attorneys general
that i can remember already said as of
right now there is no proof of fraud
trump's cyber security director said
there is no proof of fraud
trump fired him if you really want to
deal with this issue
they have to look at their own party the
voter purges
the attempts to kneecap the united
states postal service
gerrymandering that's within the state
level they are the ones
that have actually been the the
perpetrators
of what they now claim they are the
victims of it's truly a deranged
speech from the president of the united
states it is of
massive historical significance in the
sense that
at some point when this is all over um
and the historians and the sociologists
and the psychologists and the economists
and the edo i mean
this is going to be fodder for so many
disciplines for a very long time
this is exactly the type of speech that
you would look at to
sort of epitomize the absolute uh
insanity of what we're experiencing
right now
how much longer do you think these types
of narratives from trump will continue
let me know on twitter where you can
find me at
d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone
on a low carb keto diet just anybody
trying to eat healthier and cut back
on the sugar you can choose from cocoa
frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one way the easiest way the
most beautiful way to support the david
pakman show is to grab
a membership at joinpacman.com it's
quick it's easy you'll get a daily
commercial free audio
and video stream of the entire broadcast
show
as well as access to the bonus show
every single day an
extra show for our members sign up at
joinpakman.com
also you can join the discussion with 26
000 other viewers and listeners imagine
that
on our subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t this morning i
spotted an interesting post
asking on the subreddit whether rudy
giuliani could be disbarred
for these sham voter frauds hearings
that
voter fraud hearings that he is doing
setting up a parallel
legal system you know there's actually a
very interesting double-edged sword here
on the one hand rudy giuliani's presence
at these hearings making bogus claims of
voter fraud with ridiculous affidavits
and completely deranged
witnesses some of whom i'll play video
of momentarily
on the one hand his behavior is
completely unbecoming of an agent of the
court
at the same time they're not really
legally relevant hearings in any way and
what i mean by that is
they are sometimes held in hotel rooms
nobody is under oath
and they are meaningless from a legal
perspective so the double-edged sword is
if these were legal proceedings then
what rudy is doing would absolutely
uh in my view suggests that maybe this
guy should not be an officer of the
court at the same time
these are sham proceedings so therefore
they don't even really count as legal
not really they do not count as legal
proceedings they are not legal
proceedings
which makes it a very bizarre uh
situation and uh i don't expect there
will be any uh
bar repercussions for rudy giuliani
whatsoever
another post from the subreddit asking
about the upcoming elections
saying there will be more complete
trumpian candidates and even more q anon
believers elected at no
lower levels in swing state legislatures
in 2022 and 2024. i actually don't know
that the ship has sailed on that i don't
know that the ink is dry
so to speak on whether we will see
bonkers trumpian
q anon candidates in 22 and 24. i think
it will depend on
whether donald trump remains a visible
element
during the next couple of years or
whether he disappears if donald trump
i mean listen he's doing a rally on
saturday for the georgia senate races
but if donald trump disappears to just
play golf
for the next few years i actually think
that the the appetite and enthusiasm
behind these trumpian q anon candidates
will completely deflate
on the other hand if donald trump as
some have suggested
goes directly into his 2024 campaign
after joe biden is inaugurated
i do think that there is a strong
likelihood that we will see
q anon and trumpian candidates in the
midterms and maybe even into into 2024.
uh we will follow it and i encourage you
to join
the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit so we finally got an actual press
briefing from white house press
secretary
secretary kelly mcinanny yesterday
and of course with donald trump having
answered questions
only once in the month really in the six
weeks two weeks before and month
since the election there were many
important
issues that reporters had for the white
house and they finally got an
opportunity
to ask these questions of kaylee
mcinanny now
it was absolutely the stuff of legend in
the sense that communications
professionals should be studying
yesterday's kaylee mcinanny press
briefing
like the zapruder film to be perfectly
frank i'm going to go through
the dishonesty the deception the mania
of yesterday's press briefing and just
as a reminder
to lower everybody's blood pressure
kaylee has seven weeks left
she is being replaced by joe biden's
choice jenn
sackey jen sackey is very boring very
sober
very non-scandalous so there's just
seven weeks left of this
first question kaylee is asked donald
trump has filed
40 lawsuits related to so-called
election fraud
they've all been thrown out the election
has been certified
in most states does donald trump still
think he can win
check out kaylee's answer or better said
her non-answer of more than 40 cases
that have
been brought by the president's legal
team the majority have been
denied or dismissed the election results
have been certified in
all of the battleground states that the
president still think he has a path to
win
the president has said that he believes
all legal votes should be counted and
all legal votes should
not be counted and in fact the campaign
is pursuing that litigation i can't get
into the details of that litigation here
but they still do have active cases in
nevada and wisconsin how have they
overturned
the results when they've already been
certified in these battleground states
too
again the president is just looking for
every legal vote to be counted and i
will leave it to the campaign uh to
pursue their end
can the president win an election that
he lost
and kaley says well he thinks all legal
votes should be counted
and go talk to the campaign which she is
a member of remember that she is a
senior adviser to the campaign
but not today today she is white house
press
secretary every question about some
major scandal in a normal administration
you would have an entire week of press
briefings where every question from
every reporter
would be about one of these scandals we
are in such an accelerated
scandal-ridden
world that we are getting one question
about the fake voter fraud war trump has
been waging for a month
next question one question about the
alleged cash for pardons
scandal that is being investigated and
trump's possible pardons for his own
children
for rudy giuliani let's listen to how
kaylee handles that one
two questions has the president that
spoken to attorney general bill barr
since this comment came out yesterday
i'm not aware if they've spoken
i know the attorney general was here
yesterday for a pre-planned meeting with
the chief of staff and they discussed an
array of issues but
i'm not aware if the president has
spoken to him directly the president
considered
any preemptive pardons to any of his
kids that's he talking talking to um
attorney giuliani about this
i've heard no mention of any pardons and
any conversations i've had in the white
house other than
the pardon of lieutenant general michael
flynn
a three-star general who i've discussed
from this podium before
um who had his life ruined um he was a
valiant hero who served his country both
on the battlefield and then came to work
in government
that's not former national security
adviser michael flynn
that's three star general michael flynn
whose life was ruined okay so she won't
talk about the 40 election lawsuits
and she won't talk about pardons trump
has been toying
with running again in 2024.
kaylee has asked about that will she
talk about that let's take a look
sounds like he's planning to run again
do you know if that's a fact i haven't
spoken to him about that again
his campaign is pursuing litigation i
would redirect you to the campaign
now of course she is part of the
campaign
that she's trying to redirect that
question to but yesterday she wasn't
wearing her campaign hat
she was wearing her press secretary hat
so she's not going to answer that so
lawsuits no answer pardons no answer
running again
no answer we're keeping track she's then
asked
again about evidence of fraud
pointing out the reporter is that bill
barr said there is no such evidence
and again that's gonna have to go to the
campaign she tells us
maybe the discrepancy is you know you
have members of the trump campaign
coming forward and saying that there
is hard evidence of widespread voter
fraud enough to overturn the outcome of
the election and then you have
the nation's top law enforcement officer
the attorney general saying
if there is he hasn't seen it well the
attorney general was speaking to what
has come before
his desk um and again i'd point you to
the campaign for specific
um questions on this but i would just
say generally they are pursuing pursuing
civil litigation which in fact the
attorney general explicitly said
some of this is meant more for civil
litigation which is what the campaign is
currently pursuing
now bear in mind when she says civil
litigation
you can translate that to nothing that
even remotely has a shot at overturning
a single state never mind the entire
election
that's how we should understand her
saying there is civil
litigation so then vaccination finally
she will talk about vaccination to call
the vaccine the trump vaccine
that allows it to and we will have 40
million doses by the end of the year
which is a
tremendous achievement not just to have
gotten a vaccine in this time
but to have produced 40 million in
advance it's uh having a businessman as
president it's the trump vaccine
and then vaccines actually came up again
when kaylee was asked why has donald
trump been so
m.i.a as the biggest surge ever is
happening right now
some examples of you know lawmakers have
been talking about covet but i am
curious where has president trump been
in offering public leadership on this
topic of the coronavirus especially as
we've seen
cases surge we haven't seen the
president make any sort of public
comments
um or even tweets about this surge in
cases so i'm curious what sort of
examples you have
yeah uh quite a bit i mean he's created
the greatest testing system in the world
he gave
a press conference about two weeks ago i
believe
on the vaccine which he has done at warp
speed because he's torn down
bureaucratic barriers he's been
hard at work he's done i don't know how
many coronavirus task force briefings
from this podium
but the work he's done speaks for itself
the fact that now the case fatality rate
in this country
is two percent um it was six percent in
eight this is really important to
understand so
the first four questions we looked at
they were just dishonest
and and sort of mischievous non-answers
by kaylee mcinanni
here i actually want to talk about this
putting aside the hilarity of trump's
press conference two weeks ago
at which he took no questions but but
we're going to put that aside
she says trump has done vaccine
development at warp speed it's the trump
vaccine
this just isn't true the the reality is
that
these new vaccines were developed on an
mrna
platform and that is a different way of
developing vaccines than the
than the method that has traditionally
been done which takes longer
and there are companies in countries all
over the world that have developed mrna
vaccines that are all going to be ready
very very soon some of them were part of
operation warp speed some of them were
not
while in the us and somewhere in other
countries they all were developed
equally quickly and in fact
the bioentec german vaccine which then
pfizer partnered with
without taking uh uh operation warp
speed money
that has already been approved for
emergency use in the uk
so it's simply a type of vaccine
whose development is faster don't fall
for it
and then kaylee mcinanni is asked about
the threats that are being faced by
georgia election workers we talked about
this a couple days ago
donald trump keeps inspiring hostility
towards election workers
and kaylee pulls out a brilliant line
which is there's no place for violence
and however take a look yeah thanks
kaylee
just two quick questions uh georgia
officials have said election workers
there are facing threats because of the
president's
false claims about winning the state and
his it throughout the election
does the president condemn threats
against election workers or does he take
any responsibility for those threats
we condem any threats against anyone
there's no place for
violence what i will say though too
is that the president's lawyers they
were doxed by
a left organization their private
information put out so we're seeing that
happen to people on both sides of the
argument
and there's no place for that ever
anywhere there's no place for violence
but listen one of trump's lawyers was
doxxed so
what so what two wrongs make a right
what kind of answer is that even
from somebody speaking officially for
the white house
so we are getting down to the end kaylee
mcinanny has decided she's going down
with the ship
or or she is actively part of the
the group taking the ship down um
continuing to humiliate herself
every interview every press briefing
truly stunning
uh and meanwhile we are still starting
to see
we are continuing to see better said a
little bit more fact-checking happening
on fox news let's talk about that next
so this is pretty wild um in another one
of these sort of dr jekyll
and mr hyde moments on fox news trump
daughter-in-law
and campaign employee i think she's an
advisor lara
lara trump this is the wife of eric
trump not known as the smart one
eric that is she ran up against what i
guess now counts as news
on fox news and she was instantly
reality checked by fox news host martha
mccallum about
her continued claims that it's actually
donald trump who won the election
we all know that joe biden won there's
not anything that
lara or donald trump or eric trump are
going to be able to do about it now
the discussion was actually about the
upcoming runoff senate elections in
georgia
and recently the question was posed to
the rnc chairwoman ronald mcdaniel
can you trust the georgia election
given all of the fraud you claim took
place at the presidential election level
in georgia and martha mccallum rightly
brings up you know
there could be republican voters who are
hearing from trump
and others about how we can't trust the
election results in georgia
they may just stay home if they believe
their vote won't
be fairly counted and lara trump
actually takes issue
not with rana saying maybe that's true
but with martha mccallum presuming that
donald trump lost the election
and when she tries to pull this out
martha mccallum brutally confronts
lara trump with the reality that states
have certified joe biden's wins
there's nothing else to do you can't
squeeze any more water out of that rock
uh take a look at how it goes
um they're saying why should we even go
out this is already decided why should
we bother
so it that sounds to me like a a pretty
good
cocktail for having a lot of republican
voters who support the president stay
home
and then he's not going to get what he
wants which is to have his legacy
protected by these senators well look i
still think that
the president will get four more years
in office i think it'll be the next four
years because this thing is far from
over
you just had certifications today in
arizona in georgia in wisconsin you
heard geraldo moments ago say
you know it's time to accept the outcome
of this what what are you
seeing or hearing out there that that he
is not
well those certifications are just
procedural steps and the reality is the
electoral college does not vote
uh in in their states until december
14th
uh congress doesn't actually certify
anything until the beginning of january
so
we've got plenty of time sadly we have
become accustomed to having to work
twice as hard three times as hard
as a normal candidate or normal campaign
but we are
we're prepared for this and we're
prepared for the fight so understand
that
our standards are so low for what we
would expect on fox news
that this sort of counts as pushback i
mean it's laughable but
it's good that some people on fox are
doing this but the bar
is so low for what counts as holding
people accountable the casual nature
with which these people continue to
claim that essentially down is up
black is white trump won and biden lost
again it's been normalized to some
degree
in some circles it is now normal to say
trump won an election that he actually
lost now
there is something to glean from what
lara trump says
when she says the electoral college
doesn't certify until december 14th
what she's saying is we are going to
draw this out this nonsense will be
drawn out as long as possible
now will it end on december 14th it's
unclear this phase might end but they
might come up with something else
to keep going with maybe until the
georgia senate election
on january 5th maybe even until joe
biden's inauguration on january 20th
maybe even beyond who the hell knows
but back to fox news just for a moment
uh we now live in a world where compared
to tens of millions of people
fox news is the voice of reason what i
mean is
we believe based on the latest polls
that 80 percent of trump voters believe
trump won
they believe something that's just not
true that's about 75 million
i'm sorry that's about 60 million people
80 percent of trump's 75 million voters
believe trump won
fox news daytime is the voice of reason
on that issue relative to 60 million
people
uh fox news daytime is more tethered to
reality
than 60 million people on this issue
that is stunning
and we'll have more of these example
clips from fox news
on our instagram page which is david
pakman show on instagram
if you want to see some of my latest
hate mail
i i encourage you to look at this just
for a laugh
you can follow me on instagram david.pac
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
frank von hippel who is a professor at
northern arizona university and
author of the book the chemical age how
chemists fought famine and disease
killed millions and changed our
relationship with the earth
uh and frank you know in in reading
about the history of
chemistry and and chemists it seems that
a theme
with with essentially every
technological advancement in human
history
agriculture comes to mind nuclear power
comes to mind
we both have much good and the
possibility of
of much bad that am i am i correctly
understanding that that is essentially
the broad history of chemistry
yes for sure and like you're saying it's
also the history with physics and many
other fields that lead to technological
advances that we have these wonderful
innovations
but they have massive unintended
consequences
i think a lot of times when people think
about chemistry they think about the
last
100 years 150 years maybe 200 years
and they think of chemicals that include
things like
pesticides as an example or chemistry
used in in medical technologies but the
history of chemistry
really goes back much further than that
it does it really
goes back to alchemy in a way where
people were
using trial and error to find new ways
of doing things often impossible things
like trying to turn lead into gold but
those experiments led to a lot of
advancements and i would say that
modern chemistry really arose in the
early 1800s with the advent of organic
chemistry
as chemists learned how to synthesize
different kinds of chemicals that are
only otherwise found in nature and
that's what gave rise to our modern
pesticides are modern chemical weapons
and so on
it seems that correct me if i'm wrong
but there's a bit of an analogous
history
with um what what we now know of as
two very different fields astronomy and
astrology
at one point there were there was an
overlap between those and then they
eventually sort of separated it and much
the same way
alchemy which now is the subject of many
sort of pseudoscience books and
and sometimes overlaps with everything
from psychics and other things
at one point it was right there at the
start of modern chemistry as well
that's exactly right and so with the
advent of modern science
where we disprove things and we subject
ideas to experimentation of course
alchemy went away
and we have the the modern field of
chemistry rise out of that
when we start to think back in the
history of chemistry and
thinking about the the major
breakthroughs within the field
what are sort of like the top level most
important
milestones well i would say the first
one would be the synthesis of urea by
frederick voller in 1828 and that's
really the
the point of origin of of organic
chemistry
but there are many others after that and
in terms of the
history of pesticides we had the first
commercial pesticide which was called
bordeaux mixture it was a copper sulfate
solution
in the 1870s and that then led to the
proliferation
of initially uh toxic metal based
pesticides
and then we had major inflection points
in world war one and world war
ii world war one because it was
incredible
cross-fertilization of talent of
chemists who were working both on
pesticides and chemical weapons so we
had pesticides
become chemical weapons and we had
chemical weapons become pesticides
and by the end of world war one a
quarter of the artillery shells flying
over the trenches had chemical weapons
in them
which is extraordinary to think about
now just that was really a chemical war
it was the chemist who
who really decided the outcome of that
war and then things got
even more uh advanced and and
horrific in a way with world war ii
where we got the advent
of the organophosphate nerve gases like
sarin and tavin
which were developed by nazi scientists
and those developed into the modern
organophosphate insecticides after the
war
so early on in the history of pesticides
i mean
my reading of it seems to suggest
that this was really seen as just a boon
and a great thing uh the the
all positives in the prose column and
really nothing in the cons
because it allowed more food to get to
the point at which it could provide
sustenance to people and it provided an
expansion of available calories and
really solved a lot of problems that
were that were prevalent at the time
was it that were there people sounding
alarms early on
and sort of like what is the history of
when the other side of pesticides
started to become more known
yeah it's a terrific question because
initially chemists who were developing
these chemicals were
fighting scourges of humanity that have
faced us since we
started agriculture they were fighting
famine and they were fighting
infectious diseases so famine because
crops are destroyed by pests like
rats and and cockroaches and and
grasshoppers and so on but also crops
are destroyed by plant pathogens and
that's what
led to the potato blight disaster that
caused the greatest
famine ever recorded in ireland in the
1840s so
chemists were trying to fight famine and
they're also trying to fight
infectious diseases that were vectored
by animals like malaria and yellow fever
typhus
bubonic plague and so on and so the
motivations were really good
and these chemicals were quite effective
they were averting famine and averting
diseases but the first alarms really
started
i would say right after world war one
there were a lot of people getting
poisoned by toxic metals in their food
especially lead and arsenic which were
used in insecticides and often present
on produce and if
people didn't wash the produce they
could get poisoned from it but even then
it was kind of a grumbling
and then after world war ii there was
further grumbling as people saw a
widespread loss of wildlife
it really wasn't until 1962 when rachel
carson published silent spring
that we saw massive public outrage about
the pollution
and the destruction of the environment
caused by these chemicals
as well as human health effects when it
comes to there's now sort of a new
sort of newer movement of um earth
friendly
and again it's this idea of of so-called
pesticides but they're
sort of like non-chemical earth friendly
you know things i'm not actually i'm not
actually aware of what the substances
are but you'll sometimes hear hey you
know you can use uh
you spray lavender on your garden this
is not a real example but you put
lavender on your garden and then put
you know onion peels and then the
animals just don't come near
is is there does what does the the
chemistry community think about that
type of thing
can something totally innocuous really
be as effective as some of these
more uh pernicious chemical pesticides
or or is that in order to get the huge
benefit you've got the huge risk as well
yeah so it's a great question and
unfortunately with the big benefit of
using chemical pesticides we also create
our own dependency on them because these
chemicals not
only kill the pests they kill the
predators and parasites of those pests
so they kill the spiders that eat those
pests they kill the
the parasitoid wasps that infect those
pests they kill the birds that eat those
pests
and then you end up being in this
vicious cycle where you have to use more
and more chemicals to get the same yield
so it's not a simple answer and
and really there are many organic
solutions that don't require chemical
pesticides that are quite effective
but part of it has to do with the way
crops are rotated
growing a diversity of crops rather than
a monoculture if you have 10
000 acres of the same crop of course
you're going to get an outbreak of pests
because
it's this giant salad bowl for them so
we need to be thinking holistically
about how we grow our food
and at the same time reserve chemicals
for when we really need them in my
opinion that would be
for fighting infectious diseases where
we we have outbreaks of pests that we
need to handle
yeah i i found uh absolutely fascinating
um
omnivores dilemma by by michael pollan
where he talks about going to joel
salatin's farm
in i believe it's virginia and explains
how
there's this kind of vicious cycle of
you know you start to need for example
antibiotics for cows
when the cows are being fed grain
instead of grass because that's not
natural for the digestive system of the
cow
and it at least makes the case that at
some level
you can have this regenerative
agriculture that doesn't depend on
the types of pesticides that that you
write about in the book
can that can that really work at scale
yeah so i i think it's a great question
that we need to explore as a society
because it hasn't really been tried
we went from operating to small farms
throughout the world to having
industrialized agriculture after world
war
ii population has grown tremendously
and now we need to see can we do it
sustainably we have to find a way to do
it sustainably because it's certainly
not sustainable the way that we rely on
chemicals now and the damage it does to
our health and the environment
so there's going to be some kind of a
compromise where we're using the minimum
of these pesticides that that one needs
to use
while maximizing all of these other
benefits of using diverse agriculture
and
and and going to a smaller scale more
local markets why are we shipping foods
all around the world that can be grown
nearby
so we need to completely rethink our
agriculture
to go back a little bit to the uh sort
of public health side
of of of the field of chemistry
what do you make generally i mean i have
more specific questions but what do you
make generally
about the types of concerns expressed
over the last few months about
the uh coming coronavirus vaccines
some based on the speed with which the
vaccines were
developed some based more on conspiracy
theories about bill gates and microchips
but
concerns that at least some some seem in
good faith about
the makeup of the vaccines and the
storage and the long-term effect on the
body
what's your general sense of the
discussion around vaccination right now
right so i'm a big advocate of vaccines
and including
the new vaccines coming out for code
that i think they're incredibly
important
and although the vaccine for cobit 19
was developed incredibly quickly over
the last 10 months or so
the technology it's based on has been in
development for 20 years
and so it's not it's it's a new
technology to be employed
for a human vaccine but it's been in
development for a long time
and the biology is well understood so to
me the vaccine looks
very safe it looks efficacious it's more
efficacious than
many of us were expecting and certainly
i'll be
asking my parents to get it as soon as
it's available for all the people and
for the rest of us when it's available
so um i and as far as the these
um the slander against bill gates and
people like him it's just horrible here
you have someone who's
working very hard for the public benefit
using his own resources to do so
and then he's getting attacked for it i
just find it absolutely horrifying that
that's going on
one of the arguments that's sometimes
being made and to call it an argument
maybe is a bit of a stretch but one of
the claims that's being made
is that um we don't know
if by test by testing these vaccines for
a few months on people in phase three
trials
we don't know if a year two three four
years down the line there will be some
unforeseen
follow-on effects now of course it's a
sort of indefeasible argument in the
sense that
if a vaccine's been around 50 years you
don't really know that after 51
it doesn't cause some new problems so
you could always make this argument but
in terms of what we know about vaccines
what the only thing i've been able to
find about
long-term vaccine effects that go beyond
a few days
is a vaccine the exact one i forget that
doubled the risk
of guillain-barre syndrome i think from
one in two million
to one in one million over the life of
the individual
what can we say about generally speaking
at the chemical level the idea that
years down the line a vaccine could
cause something
sure and actually the example you gave
is a good one because typically where
vaccines have an adverse effect
it's at the scale of one in a million or
two in a million people that have some
serious consequence of that and if you
compare that to the
serious consequence of getting measles
or getting mumps or rubella or
or tetanus or any of these other things
that we get vaccinated
against it's it's there's no comparison
so yes there may be one in a million two
in a million people who due to their
genetic makeup and their environment
have some serious
consequence of a new vaccine but look at
the mortality rate
of people from covet 19. and we have
about one percent or almost one percent
of people infected are dying
and and that scale there's no comparison
to one in a million versus one in a
hundred
so in terms of vaccine history i think
that's what the lesson is is that
uh nearly always they prove to be safe
there are cases where they're not safe
you usually discover that quite quickly
um and uh and this happened with the
dengue fever vaccine for example and so
when those problems occur they're pulled
off the market the problem is solved and
we're very lucky to live in a time where
the science is so advanced that
something like this can be developed
this quickly rather than
us suffering through 30 years of
covenant 19 before we have a solution
very very very well said we've been
speaking with frank von hippel who
teaches at northern arizona university
the book
is the chemical age how chemists fought
famine and disease
killed millions and changed our
relationship with the earth a frank i so
appreciate your time today
thank you so much david the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pacman dot com
coupon code saves you forty percent vote
soon eighteen
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i um i i truly don't know where to
start with this today
uh last night in michigan starting at 6
p.m and going
relatively late into the night we had
another
so-called voter fraud hearing in front
of
michigan legislatures legislators
with donald trump's lawyers rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis
now to call it a hearing is a stretch
and what i mean by that is nobody was
under oath it was merely rudy giuliani
asking
leading questions to so-called witnesses
in front of lawmakers and when i say
witnesses
that term also is a question is a term
i'm using with some uh uh
it's an overstated term because many of
these so-called witnesses didn't
actually see anything that's evidence of
fraud
but they saw sometimes things they
didn't like sometimes they didn't like
how they were treated sometimes they
didn't like
sort of like the food situation at some
of these vote count locations
one woman for example said she kept
asking
voters for id when they came to vote and
nobody was giving her
id but the policy was not to ask for id
she just decided i'm going to ask people
for id and people said no
and she didn't like that this hearing
became
completely humiliating for a variety of
reasons one of which is that donald
trump's
star witness from michigan a woman named
melissa carone
completely imploded she actually seemed
maybe even impaired and got into a
strange argument with a lawmaker
now this is also just so weird
uh rudy giuliani farted on camera
while arguing with a michigan lawmaker
during during the event
and uh i i mean somehow it seems like
the the logical like nothing surprises
me at this point
uh rudy giuliani's hair dye melted down
his face making it look like his ears
were bleeding a couple weeks ago
at a press conference and now i mean
listen rudy just farting while making
this completely bizarre case and if
you're watching you will see
uh the other attorney jenna ellis flinch
when it happens and look over
it it's insane that this is going on of
order the answer that i gave you is they
didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the truth
well you probably know the truth so let
me just look at that one more time and i
know this is childish but at the same
time
the the sort of generally scuffed up
nature of everything that's going on
rudy expelling air
in the middle of bogus arguments about
witnesses who aren't really witnesses
the other attorney jenna ellis
looking over concerned like why is rudy
farting during this event take a look
the answer that i gave you is they
didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the truth
well you probably know the truth okay so
so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours i
covered some of it live
but i want to get to some of the key
moments from witness melissa carone we
previously covered melissa carone when
she appeared on the lou dobbs program
to explain what she saw and even lou
dobbs during that interview with her
couldn't
really understand what it was that she
was claiming and if you're watching
you might actually start to see here or
you will start to see if you're watching
rudy tried to sort of signal to her that
maybe she should calm down a little bit
let's just just jump right into this
absolutely embarrassing shameful
disaster
the pullback the pull book is completely
off
completely off off
i'd say that poll book is off by over a
hundred thousand
that poll book why don't you look at the
registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
did you do you even know the answer to
that
no i guess it's i'm trying to get to the
bottom here zero there's zero
so my question then is
if that's how many wait what about what
about how
what about the turnout rate a hundred
and twenty percent
well let's uh let's let representative
johnson ask his plastic questions
so the poll book number okay there
there's two things that could happen
here
either the poll book number if balance
were
caught multiple multiple times there's
two options option number one
is that the poll book numbers are not
going to match they don't
the actual not by thousands and
thousands of votes that's not what we
see right now
you take a look again take a look again
option number two is that
they essentially were for filling in
names of people who didn't vote
dead people too so is that
representative johnson ask his question
and then i thought that was his aunt
that's my my question
is why we're not seeing the poll book
off by thirty thousand votes
that that's nothing what did you guys do
take it and uh do something crazy to it
so there is witness melissa carone who
supposedly is the bombshell witness to
wrongdoing
suggesting that the wrongdoing might
have been democratic lawmakers
in michigan doing something to record
books
it's unhinged insanity
and this is what they are building their
supposed case around and i use the term
case very loosely
uh this went on the entire hearing you
keep waiting for actual
claims and proof and evidence and you
just get nothing you get speculation
from melissa carone
maybe you did something to the record
books
at another point an indian woman
said that some people think all indian
people look alike
the indian woman thinks all chinese
people look alike
a very weird moment and she refers to
some
chow who i g i guess that's like a
really weird way of saying
an asian person i've never even heard
this before and she says
this is part of the fraud that a lot of
poll workers
can't tell indian or asian people apart
just take a look like a lot of people
think all indians look alike i think all
chinese look alike so how would you tell
if some child shows up you can be
anybody and you can vote and if
somebody with my name you can't even
tell my name anybody can vote
now part of this is you if you can
believe it is moot
uh like aside from this being insanely
racist
you don't need ids to vote at a lot of
these michigan
uh polling places and so whether or not
like her argument is
listen the poll workers can't tell
indian people apart
and they can't tell asian people apart
so when they show up and show id
that could be any asian person it could
be any indian person well
they don't need to show id why are we
even talking about this
now i want to mention something else for
weeks now i've been saying when i cover
these these people are not under oath
this is not testimony this is
meaningless it's a dog and pony show
yesterday some of the democrats on this
michigan lawmaker committee
tried putting the witnesses under oath
and arguing that they should be under
oath
and that also became an argument take a
listen point of
order is to have them under oath
you're out of order as i've said this is
something
that is not done here in this state um
it's really only uh it may not be done
but you're allowing people to come in
here and lie and i know they're lying
representative you're out of order i've
given i've indulged
you but you're out of order and we're
going to move on
when putting people under oath was
brought up at the start of the
event the brilliant thing about this
that there's actually
there's there's a few different things
going on here on the one hand
the republicans and rudy keep saying
under oath this isn't court rudy said
i'm not even here as a witness i'm here
as a lawyer so i shouldn't
putting me under oath shouldn't even be
an issue republicans say this is a
hearing it's not a court of law
but then during this hearing when
lawmakers started asking some of the
so-called witnesses questions that
they didn't like rudy says objection
you just said that this is not a court
proceeding and now you're
objecting to questions as if it is a
core proceeding and you're making the
types of arguments in arguing these
objections that you would make in court
i mean it's just
absolutely and completely humiliating
and of course
it's all going nowhere that's the most
important takeaway uh from all of this
completely embarrassing completely
shameful and i don't know how much
longer this is going to go on
this next story is sort of funny because
it's actually something that
uh people donald trump has stumbled upon
threatening to do something that many of
us on the left would be very interested
in seeing him do to some degree
donald trump is now threatening to
defund the entire military
if he's not allowed to punish the
internet for being mean to him this is
the epitome of the triggered
snowflake child that is thin-skinned
donald trump
so here's what happened back when donald
trump threw that bizarre temper tantrum
last week on thanksgiving day against a
reporter
where he said don't talk to me that way
this is the i'm the president utah you
respect me
the hashtag diaperdon started trending
on twitter
trump was furious about it and believed
that twitter should be blocking the
hashtag
stopping the hashtag whatever so then
trump went on twitter and said that
unless section 230 is terminated
as part of the new funding of the
military ndaa
he will veto the entire defense funding
bill trump tweeted quote section 230
which is a liability shielding gift from
the u.s to big tech
is a serious threat to our national
security and election integrity
our country can never be safe and secure
if we allow that to stand
therefore if the very dangerous and
unfair section 230 is not completely
terminated as part of the ndaa
i will be forced to unequivocally veto
the bill when sent to the very beautiful
resolute
desk take back america now thank you
so this does require some explanation to
understand the connection like what is
the connection between that and mean
tweets about trump
and it really requires sort of
stretching your imagination to
understand
donald trump thinks that the reason
twitter allowed
the hashtag diaperdon to trend is that
twitter
is shielded from liability for the
things on its platform
by section 230. so the idea is
if you terminate section 230 twitter
would then be liable for the content on
its platform
rather than the users being liable and
so twitter would say oh
if we're liable we're going to shut down
the diaper don
but of course this is very very stupid
because first of all
why would twitter have liability because
diaper don is trending like in other
words
even if you repeal section 230 and
twitter is now theoretically liable for
the content on their platform
what is the liability with diaper don
trending like this it's just a hashtag
trump is a public person a very powerful
public person there are there would be
no repercussions for that
and secondly the hilarity is that if
indeed section 230 was terminated
twitter would probably have to ban
trump because it's trump that regularly
publishes things to twitter
that would endanger twitter trump threat
threatens people on twitter
trump incites his followers to bully
people as we've seen happen with georgia
election workers over the last week
so the incredible irony is that donald
trump seems to think
if section 230 goes away twitter will
block
diaper don but more likely if section
230 goes away twitter has to ban
trump but then we get to the really
outrageous part which is that trump ran
on the biggest and best military ever
and he claimed obama ruined the military
and obama
uh hurt and diminished the military
and his followers love the military and
on a whim trump says
if we don't make it so twitter will
block diaper done
i will defund the entire military
apparatus and are his followers okay
with this
when some democratic voters said defund
the police
they said no no no no that'll destroy
america even even though
no democrats in power want to defund the
police
almost no democrats in power want to
defund the police now trump on a whim
says defund the military because someone
tweeted mean things about me
and the cultists are mostly silent there
are
a few who are angry about it and we will
talk about that on today's bonus show
but the big takeaway here
is that january 20th cannot come soon
enough
hey uh this is a really funny caller
this is a guy who doesn't like me
but he's very polite and almost
endearing in a certain way
he calls me a fool he tells me to shut
up but
he actually is sort of polite in doing
it take a listen to this our voicemail
number of course
is 219 to david p
david uh i'm in texas i'm i'm watching
your
performance i guess the best way to
describe it
uh it's rather offensive that you keep
interjecting your opinion which is
so biased well this is an opinion show
that's what people that's
what i mean i guess that's why people
watch
do you not watch what happened
with your boy biden and his son
they're corrupt you fool
shut up thank you
shut up you fool thank you
uh i i don't know something about that
i'm uh i'm finding endearing
make sure you sign up at joinpakman.com
to get access
to the bonus show we will talk about
this uh trump
vetoing the military budget threat we
will talk about a major decision
from the department of transportation
about service animals on planes
and much much more sign up at
jointpakman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman